it's thrilling to see someone who we've
only seen under a mask reveal their face
but what are the very best face reveals
in tv history does the unmasking of one
especially fast superhero make the list
keep watching to find out
one of the most immediately obvious
things that sets the mandalorian apart
from most other live-action tv shows is
the relative scarcity of human faces in
it sure there are some bare-faced folks
in the supporting cast but our two leads
are an alien puppet that doesn't speak
and a mostly silent hero who never
removes his helmet that is until the
first season finale titled chapter 8
redemption our hero din jaren is a
member of a highly orthodox branch of
mandalorians called the children of the
watch one of the rules of this order is
that its members are never permitted to
show their faces to any other living
being and throughout the first season
din abides by this rule at all times so
much so that not even the audience gets
a chance to see his face however during
a climactic battle with the forces of
the evil moth gideon dyn is gravely
injured and finds himself in dire need
of medical attention his droid companion
ig-11 leans in to remove din's helmet so
that he can better administer treatment
but din draws his blaster and points it
at the droid saying try it and i'll kill
you it is forbidden no living thing has
seen me without my helmet since i swore
the creed i am not a living thing
ig-11 removes it anyway then for the
first time in the series audiences got a
chance to look into the big sad puppy
dog eyes of actor pedro pascal at that
moment the mandalorian became a little
less mysterious and a little more human
a trend that would continue into the
show's second season
throughout most of the run of avatar the
last airbender aang the avatar is being
hunted by a disgraced fire nation prince
named zuko they wish to capture the
avatar in order to restore zuko's honor
however in season 1 episode 13 a
different servant of the fire nation
beats zuko to it when ang is captured by
the forces of admiral zao and locked up
in the sovereign states military base
aang finds himself surrounded by guards
with his arms and legs and irons to
prevent him from using his bending
abilities for a time all hope seems lost
but then a mysterious silent figure in a
blue demon mask arrives on the scene
this stranger frees aang from his bonds
and helps him escape the base
who are you
what's going on
are you here to rescue me
however as the two are on the verge of
escaping into the woods aang's rescuer
is struck in the face by an arrow his
mask takes most of the blow but he is
knocked unconscious aang kicks up some
dust and unmasks him revealing the face
of prince zuko aang considers leaving
zuko for the guards but takes him to
safety instead aang waits alongside the
unconscious prince hoping to talk with
him when he wakes up but as soon as zuko
regains his facilities he attacks aang
forcing the avatar to flee once again
the prince never gives ang an
explanation for why he rescued him but
this moment ends up being the first sign
that there's much more going on with
zuko than aang initially believed
the twilight zone is a show that's
famous for ending its stories with a
memorable twist and perhaps no twist is
more memorable than the one that comes
at the climax of the episode eye of the
beholder the protagonist is a woman
named janet tyler she lies in a hospital
bed her face concealed by bandages
various doctors and nurses are hanging
around as well but their faces are
always off screen or concealed in shadow
the doctors say that janet is disfigured
and although she has undergone a series
of treatments in order to correct her
appearance thus far the treatments have
been unsuccessful additionally janet's
now reached the maximum number of times
she's allowed to attempt the procedure
by law this means that if it doesn't
work this time she won't be allowed to
try again and she'll have to live with
her appearance for the rest of her life
at the episode's climax when janet's
bandages are finally removed she looks
totally fine however the doctors are
horrified disappointed that there's
still been no change their faces are now
also finally revealed for the first time
and we see large nostrils sunken eyes
and a variety of swollen drooping or
asymmetrical features sure maybe the
metaphor seems a bit obvious or
heavy-handed but eye of the beholder is
still an all-time classic episode of
television even knowing the twist ahead
of time we dare to give it a watch and
not let out a bit of a gasp when that
reveal hits
death note tells the story of a
supernatural serial killer named light
yagami and the various law enforcement
officials that try and usually fail to
catch it the only person who ends up
being a true equal to light is a
mysterious independent detective who
goes by the pseudonym l and even though
l is widely regarded as the greatest
detective in the world no one knows his
true name and no one has ever seen his
face for a time l only works with
japanese law enforcement remotely
communicating over voice chat but
eventually the police begin to distrust
elle and consider cutting ties with him
completely so as a show of good faith
elle finally shows his face in season 1
episode 6 unraveling he reluctantly
agrees to meet with the team of officers
assigned to the serial killer case in
person in a hotel room when the officers
enter the room and see elle the camera
slowly pans up elle's body revealing a
skinny teenager his posture is terrible
he has bags under his eyes his hair is
long and unkempt and his clothes are way
too big for him needless to say this is
not what any of them imagined the
world's greatest detective would look
like
one of the most enduring versions of the
surprise unmasking trope is the version
that also comes with a surprise gender
reveal the best execution of this
version of the trope in recent memory
was in the game of thrones episode what
is dead may never die in this episode
catelyn stark journeys to the camp of
renly baratheon seeking to make an
alliance with the young lord however she
arrives in the middle of a tournament
when renly is watching a battle between
two figures and armor the first is sir
loris tyrell one of the most skilled
knights in westeros and renly's
brother-in-law the second is a character
we've never seen before a towering
stranger in copper armor despite being
completely unknown to the crowd and not
even a knight this strapping newcomer
defeats loris swiftly and definitively
after kneeling before the lord renly the
stranger then removes their helmet
revealing the face of a woman she is
brienne of tarth a lady who is of noble
birth and twice the warrior of any man
she's ever met but because of her gender
she is not allowed to become a knight
nonetheless because of her impressive
display of martial prowess renly agrees
to break with tradition and accept
brienne into his night's guard duh
it's one hell of a character
introduction and from here brienne of
tarth goes on to become one of the most
compelling characters in the entire
series
there are several times throughout the
series squid game when mysterious
characters are unmasked and secret
identities are revealed but strangely
enough the most emotionally impactful
unmasking in the series occurs not with
a major character but with someone who
doesn't even get a name in the episode
the man with the umbrella players have
to cleanly cut a small shape out of a
larger piece of delgona a korean
honeycomb candy if they break the shape
while doing so they will be executed by
one of the many armed guards standing
around the room toward the end of the
game one of the players player 119
breaks the shape he's trying to cut he
is about to be executed by a nearby
guard when at the last moment he steals
the guard's gun as a dozen or so armed
guards close in around him player 119
forces one of the high-ranking employees
in square masks the ones known as
managers to unmask himself and when this
manager takes off his mask he reveals
the face of an ordinary young man this
reveal finally solidifies to the
participants that whatever is going on
with this game isn't supernatural or
fantastical these guards aren't aliens
or robots these are just humans engaging
in an all-too-human form of evil before
turning the gun on himself player 119
comments you're so young how did you end
up like this moments later the
mysterious front man arrives on the
scene and without ceremony shoots the
unmasked manager in the head he then
tells his assembled masked employees
remember once they find out who you are
you're dead
in season 3 episode 2 of rick and morty
an episode called rick mansing the stone
rick morty and summer find themselves in
dire need of a vacation using rick's
portal gun the trio ends up in a
post-apocalyptic version of earth a mad
mask-esque world of murderous warlords
driving around in rusty hot rods hoping
to put off returning to earth as long as
possible summer ends up joining a band
of warriors known as the death stalkers
led by a muscle-bound warrior named
hemorrhage whose face is concealed by a
helmet shaped like a bucket later after
going on a raid together summer and
hemorrhage have an intimate conversation
in the death stalker's garage during
which summer asks him if she can see his
face in his low gravelly voice
hemorrhage replies no one has seen my
true face and lived but then he relents
removing his helmet summer is then
shocked to find that hemorrhage isn't at
all what she expected he isn't horribly
disfigured but he isn't roguishly
handsome either instead he's just kinda
dorky looking with a head that is far
paler than the rest of his deeply tan
body a bad haircut and a terrible
mustache this unexpected reveal ends up
being one of the funniest moments of the
series and completely unlike any other
face reveal in tv history
early on in the episode of firefly
titled our mrs reynolds captain malcolm
reynolds and the rest of his crew
indulge in a long night of drinking in
merriment with some friendly strangers
this is on a small planet in the middle
of nowhere the next morning mel
discovers that because he drunkenly
participated in some sort of local
ritual that he didn't understand he is
now married to a woman he just met who
are you
mr reynolds sir
i'm your wife
she's a meek and kind-hearted woman
named saffron however by the end of the
episode saffron reveals that she is
actually a skill con artist who is only
tagging along with mal and his crew so
that she can rob them of everything
they're worth in the end our heroes
manage to stop saffron's plan leaving
her behind on a snowy planet to an
uncertain fate five episodes later in an
episode titled trash malcolm meets up
with an old war buddy named monty during
their conversation monty tells mal that
he recently got married and he can't
wait to introduce mal to his new bride a
woman named bridget when bridget is
finally introduced to mal she has an all
too familiar face that's right monty has
also fallen prey to the con artist that
mal knew as saffron and her second
appearance ends up being an even wilder
ride than the first time around
the threat of superheroes being unmasked
by villains is a long-standing trope in
superhero fiction generally this idea is
played pretty straight it's assumed that
if a villain ever unmasks a hero they
can learn that hero's secret identity
and threaten them and their loved ones
however there is a particularly
hilarious inversion of this trope that
occurs in an episode of justice league
unlimited titled the great brain robbery
after the evil lex luthor's latest
invention a mind-reading machine
unexpectedly malfunctions luther ends up
swapping minds with the flash after
luther in the flash's body is chased
around the league's headquarters by the
team he finally manages to escape and
has a moment to himself in one of the
base's bathrooms looking at himself in
the mirror in the flash's body and
wearing the flash's superhero costume
luther says to himself if nothing else i
can at least learn the flash's secret
identity
he then unmasks himself and looks in the
mirror at wally west's unmasked face
after a beat he says
i have no idea who this is
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one